attention
savez vous ce qui m'arrive je me bats
avec un moustique il m'a déjà piqué
trois fois
encore raté
c'est très ennuyeux parce que je dois
aller au jardin posé pour des photos
avec zoé
or il m'a piqué une quatrième fois vous
vous rendez compte ce n'est pas possible
de poser et de racheter immobile sur un
moustique voir celle d'août les mutins
il faut que je trouve une solution
il faut pas qu'il me suive ce n'est pas
possible j'ai une idée il faut que je
lui présente quelqu'un qui ait la peau
encore plus fine et plus douce que moi
bien par là petit moustique tu vas te
régaler
léonard croix rouge at il encore
réveille toi
je dors pas je me cultive avons tous
cultivent des choux et des carottes mais
non casimir je me cultive moi je lis des
pires eh bien ça tombe très bien tu vas
pouvoir lire à haute voix ça à 10 très
rare le copain que je vais te présenter
la voilà
[Musique]
eh bien je vois que vous avez fait
connaissance alors je vous laisse tous
les deux or moi
mais il ne va pas tarder
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais d'un côté
les chocos tente de l'ofce j'ai peur
l'actu le trac comme tous les comédiens
qui entre en scène mais ce n'est pas
facile de faire des photos il faut être
naturel ou au bon moment ça doit c'est
tout un art et c'est certainement pour
ça que zoé nous a choisis tous les deux
quand tu en voilà mais si tu sais il
vaut mieux lui des crises ans
bonjour monsieur tussna e as a
service je vous avais pas vu pourquoi
vous deviez avoir une préoccupation bien
grande pour ne pas nous voir en passant
à 50 centimètres de nous oui n'ont pas
été si je rêvais voilà j'ai marché
français je pensais
et vous vous ne travaillez pas enfin si
ses fans le non non non nous étions en
train de
nous parlions de deux choses et d'autres
ah oui bon eh bien je vais vous laisser
donc
attention
les amis des chats une surprise bombe
j'ai rendez vous ici avec mademoiselle
zoé pour poser pour des photos ou c'est
parce que vous aussi
plus en est où plus on rit pas vrai à
monsieur disnat voilà l'explication de
votre mystérieuse rêverie oui je
comprends maintenant le secret vont pas
partage avec françois
gillet mon petit soyez un homme nous
rapporter mois vers brest vous surtout
la chaîne wii a voté françois et vous
partez à poser moi tout ça sur le banc
mais mais mais mais certaines l'autre
mais munich voilà la fête à l'ap à
travers d'autres merci va tout arranger
ça va beaucoup mieux
aller où travaillent à caen aujourd'hui
nous allons faire des photos historiques
ah ah ah bon ça vous serez napoléon
juni jeanne d'arc
et monsieur du snav louis xiv parfait
on savait que certains plaisirs que ce
gros ballots de casimir ne fait pas
partie des élus
mais comme je les rencontre et sur mon
chemin je lui ai envoyé sa vie en jules
césar où aller on
m'avait oublié moi très juste facteur va
vous ferez afu
ah bon
attention
briller
vers moi j'aime d'arc merci
ne bougeront plus
bien
voilà
magnifique les pauses ou 14
impeccable encore une petite dernière
voilà c'est fini il s'est fait très très
bien je commence à avoir une quand
vous avez pris au moins 16 cents photos
mais non
quatre rouleaux de 20 mobile ça ne fait
que 80 photos comme ça il y en aura au
moins deux bannis que
je pose tout ça là et je vais ranger mon
matériel
les enfants jean paul levitz venez vite
nous allons faire un jeu
et tous
regardé les enfants casimir et déguisés
en jules césar
qui était jules césar
c'est notre homme
qui a vécu il ya très longtemps
il ya plus de 2000 ans
et il a fait la guerre contre kiel
contre les gones ouraoui contre
vercingétorix pendant la guerre des
gaules et moi les enfants regardez moi
exact en qui suis-je déguisé en appeler
aux et qui était napoléon
un empereur qui a fini ta de lierre
relayée par des français
et puis kim et puis il avait gagné
plusieurs gais voyez maintenant et il a
perdu un jour puis à la bataille de
waterloo il est mort à sainte hélène et
napoléon napoléon a inventé le code
civil dont il reste encore de nos jours
certaines lois
gelly elle est déguisé en jeanne d'arc
qui était jeanne d'arc les enfants
quelqu'un qui faisait de guerre oui
c'est au début c'était une petite
gardienne de moutons sous le règne de
charles vii il y avait la guerre contre
les anglais
après elle s'est mis à faire la guerre
avec le roi et comment est-elle morte
jeanne d'arc 1 d'abord par la prison et
après le feu brûlait à roy
je perds je dirais oui monter ses
défauts portage à ce qu'il y ait chômage
ah bon c'est pour ça que c'est beaucoup
de choses monsieur du snob vous êtes
déguisé en louis xiv dans le xiv est
évidemment un roi rois de france atreg
renvoi on l'appelait comment le 14
soleil et c'est tout il habitait
quel château cette audience notamment
parce qu'il en a bit est beaucoup et
surtout le château de versailles
voilà très bien les enfants
mais rouleau mais rouleaux de photos
mérou l'autre photo qui a primé où la
photo ça c'est pas moi c'est pas les
céder
on veut pas julie nounou indiqué mme
rouleau 120 journées à la trappe du
tunnel de léonard est resté encore
je crois que nous allons aller lui
rendre une petite visite
à baba laddé jolie attrape-mouches
spécialement fait pour toi
est content je n'ai jamais vu un
moustique concis glouton et vorace
cours
de crier comme ça c'est pas drôle
c'est - françois je vous avais pas
reconnu avec vos costumes vous m'avez
fait peur mais ne sais pas
dis-moi léonard tu es passé par le
tunnel pour aller de tam à l'amont klaus
car comment sais-tu c'est facile léonard
tu oublié de refermer la la trappe site
une erreur impardonnable lui est dû à
des robes et les rouleaux de film was
held on est
sur le banc du losc c'était des rouleaux
de film oui
je comprends maintenant pourquoi il
n'était pas très efficace comme attraper
au stick
[Musique]
quoique ans et demi nous avons trouvé
des attrape mouches très efficace
[Musique]